bonjour je m'appelle william klein j'ai
29 ans je recherche un en bas dans le
domaine de la restauration ont patiné en
cuisine que ce soit en tant que plongeur
commis de cuisine ou maîtres des
cuisines j'ai le permis b et je suis dit
les jeux peu de place et de la ville de
saint-gilles avoir un nom j'ai ainsi que
ph en hôtellerie restauration en tant
que commis cuisine qui est l'équivalent
d'un c ap
mais air france 900 j'ai travaillé
récemment dans un an à l'as ptt de saint
denis
auparavant j'ai travaillé pour que le
mène pendant une saison de skins ensuite
tu travaillé pendant un an et demi dans
la brasserie en tant que commis de
cuisine j'aime bien travailler en équipe
j'aime bien raconte de belles choses
découvrir d'autres façons croyez mais ô
mes passions sont le football vtt la
quoi ca tai shan est dispo nature
j'espère que ma candidature vous a plu
appelée man amérique